a report yesterday from the washington
post and this is part of the ongoing
legal fight between daniel snyder the
majority owner of the team and his
limited partners who have been trying to
get
out they're trying to sell snyder
is throwing a wrench into that he thinks
that there are members of his limited
partnership who are trying to make him
look bad to force him to sell yadda
yadda yadda
the bottom line is a 2009
settlement has come to light involving a
claim of sexual misconduct
against snyder an incident that
allegedly happened
on a private plane back from las vegas
for
a country music awards show 1.6 million
reportedly paid on this confidential
or not agreement i don't know who leaked
it
but this reminds me of the jerry
richardson situation in carolina three
years ago this month where four
different people
who had signed confidentiality
agreements in the past breached them
and the former lawyer in me is horrified
by this because you negotiate these
deals part of the reason you get the
money is you are going to be
silent and if you don't want to be
silent don't take the money that's one
of the most important things you're
giving
to the person who's paying to settle
this case
right we're gonna make it go away i'm
not gonna have to deal with it coming
out
i don't have to go to court this is the
money you get
in exchange for giving me these things
and the silence is one of the most
important because it can create serious
complications professional
personal across the board it could force
you to have to sell your team if people
find out about it now
the reporter in me and the owner and
operator of media outlet in me says
all information is good let's get it all
out there let's have the public
discussion it's in the public interest
to know
about what these individuals are doing
the problem is if it's all out there no
one's ever going to settle these cases
they're going to have to go to court
they're going to have to fight if they
want justice because no one's going to
have the incentive
to write that gigantic check because
they know they're not going to get
silenced right so they're not going to
buy silence they're not going to buy
anything they're going to say we'll see
you in court
and they're going to unleash the lawyers
and they're going to make it difficult
and stressful and protracted
so that's where i'm kind of torn on all
of this that's assuming
in this case that the information came
from the individual it's entirely
possible
one of these limited partners well
that's obviously something else some
other
disgruntled employee of daniel snyder
over the past
10 years of which there surely are many
knew about it
and said something you speak to a
reporter under the condition of
anonymity
you're golden how are they going to
figure out it was you now snyder may try
he's trying to figure out who blabbed
to a website that tried to link him to
jeffrey epstein and there's litigation
all over the world on that
so you got to tread lightly if you're
going to
drop a dime on daniel snyder but we
don't know who
leaked in the bottom line now chris is
it's out there the nfl is going to have
to deal with it
and we saw what happened with jerry
richardson
three years ago right he ended up
selling the team this could be the first
domino depending upon what the nfl finds
as it investigates the situation from
2009 they could end up deciding to take
significant and extreme action against
daniel snyder at this point it's too
early to know but that could be
the path where this is going well yeah i
mean listen ugly
ugly day for the washington football
team yesterday i mean that's where it
has to start
owner quarterback i mean not good
stories to have around your football
team definitely
i mean with with the daniel snyder
situation i mean the first thing i
thought of mike was just that
oh one of these you know part-time or
not part-time owners part owners
minority owners whatever that is you
know that they
they had this information and they
released it that was my first
thought at least but i mean
okay yeah i mean the lawyer and you i'm
with you
these settlements seem like done they're
a thing of the past i i don't even
understand that okay that's just the
first thing i'll say how did
does that person have to pay back some
of the million 1.6 million dollar they
got like i mean
if you can prove it if you can prove it
right it's very hard to do
i've negotiated dozens of these yeah
there's a clause in there and it's a
liquidated damages provision that
basically says it's impossible to
determine the financial harm
of this confidentiality provision being
breached so if it's proven that it is
you have to pay back all of it half of
it whatever whatever number they
negotiate
and and i remember plenty of sleepless
nights worrying
about a client who may have run
his or her mouth in in a direct
or indirect way i i had one guy call me
up
trying to pitch me on representing him
and he said
well you know my buddy is so-and-so and
he told me he couldn't tell you what he
got but
he gave me a ride in his new car and
i've seen his new motorcycle i mean that
kind of i mean what do you do it makes
you nervous yeah that somebody's gonna
say something because we all want to
tell
secrets we all want to impress our
friends and it does make you nervous
and if it does come out and it can be
traced back to you you've got a problem
and you have to may have to pay back the
money
good luck proving it though that's the
reality how do you ultimately prove it
now in this day and age
if people are passing around the
information on one of these yeah
then you've got a problem right right
yeah so uh
but but but and anybody and and anybody
else may walk away from this snyder is
not going to walk away from this well
that's
going to want to find out who did this
well yeah i mean really like
you know who did it whatever doesn't
matter
damage is done you know in the court of
public opinion here we go
all the rumors and things we heard about
in the spring
all right and all those things what's
true what's not careful careful careful
i know i'm just i'm saying i don't i
don't want to be representing you
in a lawsuit with daniel schneider so
well don't worry i'll call a better
lawyer don't worry don't you worry
you'll call a more expensive one yes
it's a far more expensive one
but no i i i'm not trying to say any of
those allegations are true or anything
what i'm trying to say though is the
casual football fan or whoever that's
out there
is just going to see that from yesterday
and go oh well
some of that stuff in the spring must be
true then i mean there there it goes
there's the confirmation
it's just it's a bad culture around
there there's something wrong
you know and that's really the problem
what comes out yesterday is it just
whether it's true or not some people are
going to see it and move on with life
and just go oh that confirms what i
thought about the football team and
that's thanks for daniel snyder and the
washington football team
and chris i think snyder had found a way
to create this balance whether it was
effective or not
where there's a bad culture in the
organization but he's kind of an
absentee landlord and he's not part of
it and it's other people and
there wasn't anything that directly
pierced
through to him remember that first
report we were waiting for
that that had been creating buzz about
what's going to be in it and that's what
sparked this this story that
that tried to link him to jeffrey
epstein and has triggered all this
litigation all over the world to get to
the bottom of
who was telling these lies about daniel
snyder what their motivation is
subpoena after subpoena after subpoena
and then it wasn't until the story about
the video with the outtakes from the
cheerleader shoots and that's when it
started to
kind of close in on snyder a little bit
now you have this issue
the nfl's got a problem here and that
independent
investigator who i never thought would
be independent because daniel snyder
hired beth wilkinson to be the
investigator the league took over the
investigation
and his worst nightmare very well may be
that she is
behaving independently and she is going
to get to the bottom of this and it is
going to create
a mess for daniel snyder where he
ultimately may have to
sell the team and oh look what hey your
punishment is you get five billion
dollars
for your asset you know that jerry
richardson got a couple of billion yeah
donald sterling when he
had to sell he got billions right for
the clippers steve ballmer bought them
for 2 billion i think which was a
ridiculous amount at the time
but what do you do you can't take the
franchise away from the guy you're
forcing him out he's going to sell it
for whatever it's worth
and if that's what happens that's what
happens and the punishment is
taking that that point of pride that
thing that the person
wants to keep away from them and that
may be what happens we don't know at
this point it's too early to tell
but i think once they investigate
exactly what happened on that plane or
what's alleged to have happened on that
plane
and if they get the facts and if snyder
allows them
to speak to the person if the person
cooperates it it could
spiral out of control i would think so i
mean i you know it certainly seems like
it's
you know teetering on the edge right now
the nfl can't be happy about this
i mean come on you know this is one of
the 32 owners of the league basically
having a lot of issues and a lot of bad
talk that
of course reflects poorly on the shield
and all of those issues whether they're
true or not when we know
sometimes that stuff just sticks either
way so
yeah i mean this this doesn't seem like
this assault
on daniel snyder is going to stop
anytime soon mike i mean
whoever is out to get him whoever it is
i mean there seems to be you know uh a
consistency in trying to attack him and
not gonna
not gonna let it die down or let it go
you know a long period of time without
throwing something out there and that's
that's gotta be troubling to the nfl
that there might be more stories to come
or who knows what else is out there
and we are three years removed from the
original
jerry richardson incident where we
became aware of these confidential
settlements and
i remember thinking at the time that
there surely are more
mark libovich in his book big game the
nfl in dangerous times he
has a passage in there where he talks
about how
the nfl fears that this is the tip of
the iceberg
i'm surprised that three years later
this is the only one we know about
because
large profitable businesses get sued
all the time just because you've been
sued doesn't mean you've done anything
and just because you've settled a case
doesn't necessarily mean you've done
anything there are plenty of motivations
to settle now
when you're talking about 1.6 million
the message that gets sent
is something
something close to the line right
something at least
close to the line right something that
falls into that range of where
reasonable minds may differ and a jury
could
find against you there's there's an
argument that's been made to the person
involved
that you have reason to not fight this
tooth and nail because you could you
could lose the case so you know
hey if if you think it's frivolous then
fight it if you think there's no merit
then defend yourself and and see that's
the difference
between the scorched earth campaign
we're seeing from snyder as it relates
to
the false story trying to link him to
jeffrey epstein let's be clear that was
false
we never touched it we never mentioned
it we never got close to it i knew it
was
it was a a a a a flaming hot potato
right from the moment i first saw that
someone was talking about this and kind
of a reckless irresponsible
and uh potentially liable for a lot of
money way
but in that case snyder's in the right
if he does try to aggressively get to
the bottom of who blabbed
there's still this sense of well maybe
he did something here he paid 1.6
million so
you know the more you push this one the
more you remind people that you paid one
exact six million
for right something so this is gonna be
a tough one for him he's wired
by all appearances to just kind of
knee-jerk litigate and flood people with
paper and you've got the lawyers that
you can
afford and you just get overwhelmed and
you learn a valuable lesson as does
anyone else who may cross you in the
future so
look it's not a good posture for the
team the league's got to figure out what
happened
and we could find out i don't know days
weeks months down the road
that there is a significant consequence
for daniel schneider
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports